thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys this is sort of a weird one
that we're about to do is it though
maybe I don't know maybe it's on right
off I feel like this is right up our
alley this is we've been meaning to be
more transparent with this company
because like people be dropping left and
right like flies and [ __ ] dude and any
day like they say like I just fire
everybody all the time but sometimes you
hire people though yeah I want to show
like hey I fire people but I also hire
people and I'm gonna bring y'all into
this process you're a job maker I got a
[ __ ] Berry seat on my mouth all right
we're gonna do a JK job interview yeah
welcome Justin
Couch JK casting cows is this the first
time we've done a JK first time right
here dude the first time off camera with
our clothes on still yeah I don't wow no
we haven't done many job interviews I
think the last person we did was Pat
good old Pat oh that was like four years
ago damn yeah because you just you
didn't get interviewed you just came on
we told your ass you're invited you just
asked me you got forcefully I just kind
of ended up there ducted into the
careful boys room I didn't invite I
didn't we didn't even do a job interview
with Justice you know how Justice came
on board how do you come on it's because
can supposed to do the job today and Ken
was like I can't make it you do it for
me oh can can't huh
[Music]
what's Cam doing today anyway why is he
so [ __ ] doing this somewhere [ __ ]
Iowa
um other clients other videos yeah this
isn't about cans about you buddy justice
so go ahead and say your name full name
please through the camera okay the
introduction is very cringe so I know
you guys will make fun of me but it's
just you and I just us
my name is Justice wow how many chicks
have you used that on well I just made
it up right now I know it's just you and
I just you and I it's just you and I and
I well I just made it up right now four
times wow wow or guys or guys no [ __ ]
girls girls okay so that's not your
legal name your parents didn't come up
with that yeah so real legal name is
Justin but then since I moved to
California recently
um there's too many adjustments so I was
like okay let me try to be different so
I put just us where did you come from
where there weren't enough Justin's oh
well in Maryland I'm from Maryland no
justice in Maryland no there's so many
just marilas but then in this field I
wanted to be something different so
Justice that's pretty cool yeah all
right what are you what are your three
most uh what are your three weaknesses
yeah yeah yeah
oh nothing yeah I'm pretty red flagged
yeah but the Jade names
I like Perfect People
so far he's checking out all right
okay really though what's uh what's one
thing that you've never told anybody
publicly before that's [ __ ] hilarious
you know that's actually one of the
questions I ask people when I interview
them really and then one of the craziest
ones I was like interviewing some for
for Barbara and one of them told me uh
I think he hit his mom or something but
she was asking for it I haven't told
anyone but I beat the [ __ ] out of my
mouth
thank you for your honesty
I'm still tired of them [ __ ] the story
was good I forgot how I got there and
bar was like I could relate I bit myself
you're the man for the job the [ __ ] out
of her yeah she was half she had to call
you she was she in the Joy Luck Clan
if someone asked me that [ __ ] I would
have been like top of your time to hit
your mom no no no no my mom would beat
my ass she wants a tiger mom but she's
very nice I think one thing they never
told anybody never told anybody publicly
publicly publicly when I first moved to
us I moved to Maryland and the first day
of school I got bullied and that bully
became my best friend
you know what I was extremely wholesome
I don't like it when people rat
themselves out so that's a that's a
that's a negative for me I would have
been like if if someone asked me that
question I would have been like you're a
stranger I am exposing no secrets very
confusing how that's heartwarming though
how did they bully you yeah okay I
didn't speak any English were you where
are you from originally from Korea so
I'm the Korean
um
okay you get a little point for that I
like Koreans if you wouldn't say Vietnam
though we're in trouble they're number
one Asian in our list somehow yeah top
three in Russia
right yeah but I'm Korean but I grew up
with a lot of um Vietnamese and Thai in
Maryland I mean I'm Korean but I didn't
really like a dirty Korean oh
Korean friends yeah yeah it's weird I
don't know I was like like David yeah
with Koreans so can but Ken's been
teaching me a lot of Vietnamese culture
everything what are you teaching in
Vietnamese wait wait I want to know go
back to your story you came to Maryland
dude backtracking okay first was a
Chinese girl I still remember her name
Juliana she sped on me whoa
was she a tourist was she a checkup but
then I
feel like you're like a second grade
eight years old so we got to spit yeah
and then during recess you know during
lunch time when I was playing soccer
because that's what Korean kids did you
know play soccer and stuff and then a
Thai kid came in and then he stole my
shoes so for though half day I'll
shoeless yo the other Asian she's just
walking around like just on your ears
just one shoes one shoes oh man isn't
that said you you moved to Maryland and
you get bullied by other Asians yeah
what the hell because and I don't speak
English so next day I bring my
non-speaking Korean immigrant parents
you know and then we're trying to find
this kid like I don't know his name but
I remember he was kind of shorter than
me oh your parents came with you to try
and get your shoes back well sure well
they try to get in trouble but we got
the shoes back at the end of the day
because he would bring it out um
no no interview's not done just wait
right there welcome what's good what's
up man Anthony I'm Joe nice to meet you
finish it up man I have this coffee Ryan
coffee nice to meet you justice I have
your coffee he's already a killer keep
that he's already killing and look at it
he's getting caught he's very
professional when he when he was
bringing the lights I like him more than
can immediately all right all right the
fact that he's got this even if it's can
editing all right it can side talk I do
like it more than you but we still like
you the thing I like about Koreans is
they're very attentive oh hey Justice
what's up man it's right here oh wait
what happened this is the one comment
too much we're deliberating okay all
right so how did uh you kill your bully
in the end how did you get your shoes
back okay at the end of the day I got my
shoes back and um the next day I got
pissed so I brought my Korean parents
and didn't speak English so through my
English teacher which is Esau they teach
you English to like International
students and then since my parents can
communicate they have to bring a
translator so we're going around the
whole school trying to find this kid
dark skinned sure shorter than me like
Asian kid and we found them yeah and
then we found out his name is Mimi and I
do you make fun of him for it yeah I was
like MiMi like I never heard me what a
dumb name right yeah I mean all I hear
is Kim Park Lee's you know I never heard
me me before yeah and then his sister
name was pimi oh so you ripped them hard
yeah ripping on them damn so we asked
him like so why'd you take my shoes and
he said I want to become your friend and
then it's a tight tradition do you know
that oh no
I lied I made it up so yeah so and then
we became best friends but found out
that his family is pretty wealthy
um and then that's how I got my kind of
like your settlement check
he settled out for the did you ever get
your shoe back yeah at the end of the
day
it was like uh the first day that I got
bullied wow yeah and then the next day I
brought my parents in and this is the
guy that became your friend yeah he's
like my best friend though oh damn wow
that's dope you got a special message
for this guy yeah
um I know you're back in Thailand we'll
visit I mean I'll visit soon okay making
it too real how about a message for
Juliana Juliana Juliana I love you [ __ ]
you should become your friend too oh did
she become your friend too yeah but then
she moves away why did she spit on you
did you ever ask her I don't speak
English so I'm like no later did you
ever find out later no because she moved
away
maybe she liked me too I don't know I
was like baby dude yeah that's the
Chinese tradition teasing and people
like pulling pranks can turn out to be
like Oh I'm being bullied like a
[ __ ] yeah when you're younger
it's like kind of like a weird method of
flirting yeah how old were you I was
eight but I was used to it you used to
getting spat on no because like in Asia
you know that's like you know teachers
hit you still back in 2006 so they still
hit you you know they do everything the
good old days
you didn't bring your homework ruler you
know so it's like I was used to it but I
was like spit I was like oh that's
different so so what was your what was
your first time hearing of or first
impression of just kidding just kidding
so you guys have like a core memory in
my heart and you know like I grew up
like this um like watching you know all
my friends and even with the Thai um
friend too like we just hung out at his
house so like there's a group of Asians
that were there weren't a lot today's
video is brought to you by audible if
you guys are interested in like one of
the most interesting people in the world
I highly recommend this book and to me
it's an honor to even be called his
friend uh but Tim Kennedy has a new book
called scars and stripes and man this
guy has been a firefighter he's been a
police officer been in Special Forces
fought in the UFC during the whole like
crazy Afghanistan thing he has so many
jobs yeah he went over there he helped
um like over 10 000 people escape
Afghanistan like wow his life is just so
insane and it was cool to like hear how
proudly he feels to be to be American so
and one thing I love about audiobooks
too is that you get to hear it in their
voice so sometimes like you know you
lose emotion or whatever when you're
like listening and when you're reading
that text so audiobooks is my favorite
way because even our other friend Bobby
hundreds I listened to his book too and
it's just way different when the author
is speaking it to you oh and yeah so if
you get Audible
check out some of your favorite people
and I'm sure a lot of them have written
books and you get to listen to them and
if you remember you get to choose one
title a month it's pretty freaking
awesome and they have so much more than
just books okay they got audible
Originals they got comedy motivational
speeches they got all kinds of good
stuff for your ears to feel Joy let
audible help you discover new ways to
laugh Be Inspired or be entertained new
members can try it for you for 30 days
visit audible.com off the Record or text
off the Record to 500-500 that's
audible.com off the Record or text off
the Record to 500-500 to try Audible for
free for 30 days audible.com off the
Record but then we all watch like J
Kitty news JK films
um news and just like other YouTuber
creators wow that's crazy the Schumer
was just hitting us all right who's your
least favorite brown nosing how close is
he to getting the job one it's looking
pretty bright the future's looking
pretty bright I like it I like it mama
taught me well yeah yeah yeah what
brings you to California California so
before this I was like K-pop tour
manager uh I was working behind the
scene because I always loved the
entertainment I was doing North America
tours with a lot of artists but and then
I was like wait I feel like I can do
that you know I can't sing I Can't Dance
I mean Ryan's here Anthony's here I
enjoy dancing
um so I was like let me go to acting
school so I went to acting school in New
York for a little bit and then I prepare
about a year because it's like coven hit
no more concerts all the artists were
dying I mean not dying
oh [ __ ] all the artists were hurting
stay with me yeah so I had to learn the
behind the scene first go to school a
little and then I moved here to do
acting acting and um just entertaining
but you're a K-pop manager yeah tour
manager wow which artists uh amber Lou
was the first oh Amber I didn't manage
fully to the tour I started as a
volunteer there yeah her first tour and
second tour oh and then I and then I
went to New York because the manager
liked me and then that's where I got
scouted by different agencies wow that's
dope man what does a tour manager do so
since I was Korean and some other
artists were Korean uh there was no
company in New York they bring the
Korean artist to North America and then
I had to do translating to them not to
pretty much jobs here like kind of help
them be like an artist manager make sure
they go to the hotel fly bags everything
yeah uh merch
um all these stocks ticket sales
everything like that so Korean
babysitter yeah gets pretty difficult
yeah that's why he's so good with the
coffee and getting everyone's things and
all that because I was like
that's very that's like PA stuff yeah
that's like um on film you know like
like a like a good assistant that's just
like grabbing everything immediately
that stuff has to be trained because not
everyone thinks like
the extra mile when it comes to oh this
guy's order is gone oh what about this
oh this guy didn't get his food people
just order it and then they'll be like
uh oh there's two plates missed yeah
that's what happens they go oh
Uber Eats messed up not me
but then like he immediately starts
solving so it's my food I don't know why
food but they're fancy boy
but it's like you have to train people
to like okay so if that happens like you
have to create Solutions yeah like it's
like oh well my food came how about I
just like give them that and I'll just
order mine on the side or like whatever
but then like a lot of people that just
started they don't know that they go oh
it just I [ __ ] ordered it but I don't
know I didn't come
what are you gonna eat Anthony
exactly
we don't feed Anthony at the show I
guess huh let me ask you an on-the-job
question oh okay okay so you know me and
Joe own this place right there's a JK
let's say there's a JK cash register oh
what oh this is Jackie Castro that's
where all the JK money goes through okay
let's say one day
you come in here right
and uh you see me like this
I'm like opening the JK cash register
the money out right taking funds for
himself and then you're like
and then all right Joe comes in do you
tell him
would you wrap me up I mean by the
street you're not supposed to you know
say the name a lot of things yeah but
then I think the true truth will reveal
itself later so how does that happen
though
I uh
you wrapped me up cause that's not
[ __ ] up but then also are you
dishonest with Joe because you know who
stole the money that Joe comes up what
the [ __ ] how if it's gone oh [ __ ] half
the JK's money's gone what do I do what
the [ __ ] was going on yeah what are you
gonna say what's the move a lot of
pressure on me now yeah
can we go to the next question
this is the final question that's the
final question what do you do dude I'll
let you guys handle it
so as Joe is getting pissed [ __ ] where
the [ __ ] is the money at and Bart's like
he's like what I thought it was here and
then Joe's punching more walls holes in
the wall and then you're looking at Nick
Nick's looking at you and he's like
[Laughter]
so it's very confusing message
I'm not in that like that Circle I say
none just
stay out of it and let you guys do it
because it's not my position to you know
interesting okay so you're Pro stealing
gotcha
that's very interesting plus three and
minus three oh my God
it's neutral thank you oh wow I respect
that you're not a rat yeah but it's
minus three because you didn't tell me
you don't
[Laughter]
rap gotta I gotta it's it's uh it's
closest to ten he's not at that ten yet
dude who do you think is most likely to
steal in this room oh yeah yeah it has
to be you have to pick somebody
no skipping questions here buddy
and I won't take it personal I promise
oh really none of us will really we'll
we'll never forget oh but you gotta have
a reason why you think it's them yeah
I'll just pick me then oh I won't steal
though
because I don't want to say you you
everybody here I'll just say me and I
won't though I'm not gonna hire you then
you have my verbo agreement if you can't
frame somebody on JK you know that's
your most likely but you won't do it
you like to do self-sacrifice a lot it
seems like right you don't want to
burden other people no that's good it's
great when people say I'm down to go
above and beyond
are you one of those peoples oh yeah of
course of all time well we're starting
to only fans and what
um only fancy better like we're actually
yeah yeah and are you down to do nudes
me yeah can't say that you were
comfortable with your body oh really I
mean if you guys do it I'll join you
guys it's the way he said me he's like
your resume says you're done
are you done with nudes
this is a casting couch bro yeah I did
we got a lot of black couches over here
oh yeah
like each of those black couches we
shouldn't have sat them on a black couch
that should be the next JK interview
dude you think the cushions are worn
just because of time
I don't think anyone's putting that down
ever again
above and beyond never above and beyond
that's what you said
hey that's you we're gonna start a
Snapchat premium yeah we want you on
there what do you think the extra mile
means all those coals get removed
it's like hey you're really down to
expose who you really are there's
nothing more real than your naked body
that's true yeah that's where you gotta
add additional skills it's like speaks
three languages proficient and Excel can
do nudes
you gotta update your resume my man oh
lord well here's the thing man you're
already working here without even a
[ __ ] interview so you're hired
[Applause]
[Music]
even today like it was like dude we need
somebody hey get your ass over here
player man thank you good job Justice
yeah man I don't know maybe if you guys
want us to fire him or whatever just
leave a comment below what do you guys
think your future will be reliant on
just this video alone in the comments
yeah I like this guys yeah he's awesome
he's a good Korean yeah
[Music]